hommes et femmes politiques de
l'opposition après ceux de la majorité
et du gouvernement hier Laurent Fabius
son portrait aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen
la fille de son père complice mais en
même temps vous allez le voir jalouse de
son indépendance et qui entend bien
faire prendre un tournant au Front
national le rajunir en quelque sorte
Françoise David Bernard conard Arab sont
aussi des Sémites l'antisémitisme doit
pas s'appliquer seulement aux Juifs
voyons je pense que les Français sont
des Français et qu'à ce titre ils
méritent la protection du Front national
quel qu'il soit et d' qu'il viennent ce
soir-là la parole était dans la salle et
Marine Le Pen avait forte affaire pour
calmer les ardeurs verbales de certains
militants ou sympathisants du Front
national personnellement ça ne me
gûerait absolument pas qu'un Tiger
risque 50 prisons Paris devenu tag City
alors tu sais que les barêes qui sont
dans le code pénal sont desà très
importants mais le problème c'est que
ils ne sont pas appliqués car la
benjamine de Jean-Marie Le Pen donné une
mission dédiaboliser comme elle le dit
elle-même le Front national bref le
banaliser écarter les petites phrases
qui ont fait la réputation sulfureuse du
parti d'extrême droite et de son
dirigeant Marine Le Pen se veut la
porte-parole d'une nouvelle génération
au terme d'extrême droite elle oppose
droite nationale mais ses adversaires
n'y croient pas on pouvait caricaturer
facilement Jean-Marie Le Pen avec Marine
Le Pen c'est plus difficile parce que
elle donne le sentiment que finalement
elle est une responsable politique comme
les autres ce qu'elle n'est pas au
regarde du fond de sa pensée voilà c'est
ça c'est le menteur professionnel tout
son père en femme disent ses partisans
marine ou le clone de Jean-Marie affirme
d'autres plus perfidesin dit je suis
pour mais il faut l'appeler autrement
des trois filles Le Pen elle est celle
qui porte sur ses épaules l'héritage
politique de celui qu'on surnomme le
ménir et ce même s'il s'en défend rien
dire je ne l'ai jamais incité à faire de
la politique et je dirais même que les
difficultés avec lesquelles elle a vu
son père repr prise aurait pu la
décourager je crois que Marine est doué
pour faire de la politique Mo je crois
Marine Le Pen est en campagne tête de
liste Front national en région
parisienne elle
veut tu rêves de de prendre la l' de
France mais je parlais pas de moi tu
sais je pense TJ alors elle laboure le
terrain àre sans relâche les h
départements de la grande couronne ça
passe
bien on dis pas dur d'être la fille de
votre
père j'ai toujours eu un caractère
qu'est-ce qu'il est pas de chix sur le
très bon côté mais enfin il il a au
moins le mérite d'exister et d'être
d'être je crois un caractère
relativement fort donc j'ai jamais de
problème pour me faire un prénom c'est
plutôt son patronyme qui dérange affirme
Marine Le Pen et quand comme à Provin
ville gérée par l'UMP elle trouve des
portes closes c'est vers ses adversaires
de droite et notamment Jean-François
Copé qu'elle se tourne plutôt que
d'invoquer le
hasard comme vous voyez il y a des
opérations techniques qui qui se
déroulent ici mais j'avais déjà dit que
nos adversaires étaient prêts à user de
toutes les méthodes pour nous empêcher
de faire campagne mais là
j'avoue c'est d'une d'une bassesse assez
grande Marine Le Pen veut faire des
prochaines élections une réussite pour
le Front national officiellement bien
sûr elle ne brique pas la succession de
son père mais elle sait qu'un succès
dans les urnes lui facilitera la tâche
pour accéder à la tête du parti et
peut-être fonder une dynastie Le Pen